et
[Musique]
après la tragique affaire de la machine
à pilules qui a failli leur coûter la
vie les shadoks sont revenus à la
méthode de ponte classique
ce ne fut que petit à skis et quinquas
au rythme de prod âge d'un chat d'oc qui
n'avait pas été fait pour ça que les
shadows que se repeupler
ils avaient bien du mal le ministre de
la population avec ses enfants il
grandissait pas vite car sur la lune en
ce temps là il n'y avait pas grand chose
à se mettre sous la dent en cherchant il
avait trouvé dieu harricourt qui
restaient dans le tas de détritus et qui
passait son temps à ne rien faire le
haricot et pour nourrir ses enfants il
voulut culte idée des haricots
alors le voilà qui plante son haricots
malheureusement la culture du haricot
sur la lune et quelque chose
d'excessivement dangereux à cause de
l'atmosphère qui est à l'intérieur vous
comprenez dès que le highco commence à
tousser
ça fait un peu à l'eau pour l'atmosphère
vous pensez c'est une aubaine et l'on
pense qu'il faut aussi tout pour aller
se promener dans le haricot ou toutes
autres légumes qu'on peut mettre à sa
disposition
et voilà le haricot shadoks qui se
mettent à puce
à gonfler et la lune pendant ce temps là
naturellement à se dégonfler se
dégonfler bien tous les shadoks n'ont
plus rien à se mettre sous mais qui est
cette fois là encore ils faillirent péri
tout ce qui reste est affaire c'était
bon pétards âge qui vous remet pour
l'atmosphère dans la lune et tout ça
c'était de la faute aux shadoks
populations qui ont comme une fois
n'avait pas fait son devoir et à mes
passions des ifi culture des haricots
dans le ciel gégène ça le gênait
énormément aujourd'hui 7 et des haricots
et puis demain les shadoks sur les
laisser faire ça serait des carottes et
des navets qui souhaitaient s'y pouilles
et bien lui ils en avaient assez et la
lune ils allaient l'abattre et manger
des derniers shadoks qui restaient voilà
ce qu'il allait faire lui j'adore bien
tout était perdu
il aurait fallu partir dans les espaces
interstellaires à la recherche d'une
terre plus hospitalière mais avec quoi
ils n'avaient même plus une vieille
fusée ni rien alors jouer le tout pour
le tout les shadoks décidèrent qu'il
partirait quand même qu'il partirait
avec ce qu'il leur restait sous la main
c'est à dire qu'il partirait dans le
cosmos avec la lune
voilà
[Musique]